on s'est mis d'accord avec quelques
copains a été chercher des trucs chez
toi quand même jeu
[Musique]
antoine est avec nous ce soir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
excellent le formidable eric antoine
fonte d'arcueil bon goût à waimes
événements ou même à la télé j'aimerais
qu'eric antoine nous a fait une petite
surprise n'arrive plus j'aimerais qu'ils
nous fassent au tour de magie parce que
vous l'attendez touche contemporaine a
alors que les gros tu veux ici c'est
chez toi c'est ton édition c'est ta
chance et tu ton émission cyril non tu
es pas très grand mais je t'aime
beaucoup ok je veux pas qu'on ait changé
l'est le micro le métro n'importe quoi
c'est la première émission on échange
des baisses qui est une musique sans
rigoler on en est
[Musique]
on s'est mis d'accord à quelques copains
a été chercher des trucs chez toi quand
même jeu c'est un petit dessin c'est un
message dans une bouteille
tu vas regarde c'est sympa mais bon ça
c'est un truc assez facile à voler je
t'avoue que d'accord youtube tu as une
petite fille ouais ouais c'est un deux
et c'est vrai que j'ai déjà ma fille
c'est un dessin de ta fille au gardien
sur un lieu mais chez rose anna song for
gold c'est un vrai dessein de ma fille
je vous jure que c'est vrai il ya un
micro quelques pompes
il est dans ton slip on a deux il ya des
trucs cachés dans le costume très
souvent c'est dans la manche oui là je
te montre
[Musique]
c'est eric antoine
allez c'est parti on a un truc de folie
un truc sur twitter alors il faudrait
que vous connaissiez
donc à mon compte twitter ou au compte
de tpm piquante de cyrielle compte de
tpm j'envoie à twitter maintenant est ce
qu'on le voit la caméra est ce que vous
envoie ses recruteurs venus du futur
c'est une prédiction chers amis accord
et pmp officiel cyril hanouna des huit
magie observé c'est quoi la prédiction
c'est une prédiction il a écrit magie
observer notre tp mp intensément
exclusivement langoureuse encore je vais
t'expliquer pourquoi cette prédiction
dans quelques instants j'ai un petit peu
comptabilisé si vous les amis que vous
avez sur twitter les uns les autres
alors bien sûr et nohra deux cent trente
sept mille personnes te suivent tous les
jours fort c'est à dire c'est une ville
entière les gens adorent
isabelle 40 2006 gas est une sous
préfecture en 335 mm
288 pour thierry alors c'est quand même
très bon gilles 72 mille fans de ragga
c'est quand même camille regarde la
tronche photos de camille il est papa
le mec est photogénique tous les angles
sont bons c'est un acteur de cinéma
c'est extraordinaire et jean-michel
342000 follower commun il ya des vieux
sur twitter après ta françois françois
442 non mais pas 2000
[Applaudissements]
sa fille
il n'y a pas de venus privé le mec n'a
pas de téléphone et mme bernard
alors là ça 90 100 90 mais pas de 1000
non plus demander mon cher s'il de
mélanger ses cartes le snj a pas de
marco dos on sait pas lesquels et lequel
on va utiliser cette part est chanceux
magazine cet hebdo extraordinaire quand
on est d'accord je ne sais pas où sont
les cartes postales
je pique comme ça d'accord et la
première carte postale sur laquelle va
tomber ça sera donc là près de la
prédiction de ce soir j'espère on
retient c'est à dire que là on a trouvé
on a eu plusieurs cartons n'est ce pas
grave on d'apprendre la première
d'accord la personne choisie ce soir au
ice bernard montiel bernard montiel 190
personnes regardons maintenant seul
tweet venu du futur
ouais alors ces comités pmp officielle
des vies tout ça ce soir regardez bien
si on prend la phrase qui est ici il ya
une lettre une première est qu'il
commence chagnon ses intrigues m ou
magie au observer notre nom le thé de
tpm
après le i2 a tancé mans le hull
exclusivement et le l de l'engouement
20e
o nt y ai eu l mondiale géraldine c'est
à vous de jouer
vous allez choisir qui de ces deux
heures il y en a combien qui vont aller
vite et il y en a au moins deux qui vont
éviter un fermez vos yeux 2,3 à daisy
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et